today we have got something in the mail
and I'm so excited to try these out I
saw that these were announced fairly
recently these are razors hammerhead
true wireless earbuds feel like this is
the earbud season I think everybody has
been launching these things we've had
Amazon Google Microsoft Apple like
everyone is getting into the wireless
earbuds space
I love razors I'm excited to check these
out so let's pick them out of their
little home I really like that it says
ultra-low latency not only is that great
for gaming but for editing I just want
you guys to know that I changed this
light to green for razors and just in
case you didn't notice this knife is so
sharp
sometimes I spin this not enough
ultra-low latency touch enabled voice
assistant water-resistant ojou 5.0 an
auto pairing charging case and earbuds
sleeves alright I love when I'm greeted
with a letter it's so personal oh I love
the packaging this is nice I like that
they're already out here and displayed
you've got your case charging cable and
our earbuds that are left right case
cable just make sure I just don't want
to be upset later when I find out there
was a surprise at the bottom I
definitely thought that Apple was going
to go with a matte black earbud this
year but so far I mean the years not
over but they did just come out with an
ear pods Pro and they were not matte
black let's put these in the charging
case I'm already into it if these fit in
my ear well I'm gonna be so happy oh
look at this you guys have been
following me for a while there's one
thing that I absolutely love whenever I
get these cables with point-and-shoot
cameras it's like the best thing ever
because I love being able to just attach
things to other things okay so my wrist
doesn't fit in here well actually it
does but I think most people's wrist
probably would not fit in here it fits
perfectly on mine was this designed with
my wrist in mind probably not but I
think it's
you're thinking there's no way this will
fit on anyone elses wrists I mean if you
have a small wrist maybe do you think
this his so small it's a solid attempt
ain't catches nothing
so if you have a small wrist this will
work but honestly this is great to just
hook it on to things let's just ignore
the fact that my dog is barking it also
comes with some little ear covers here
so we'll put those on I wonder if I need
to put those on I almost feel like I
don't have to do I look cool or what
I already feel cool okay I think I
should put these on and love the
charging case charges with us PC so
let's get these paired up to my phone so
I can hear what they sound like
[Music]
here they are
I'm listening to tool right now they're
also touch sensitive so if I double tap
it'll change the track which is great as
far as the sound goes I mean I think
they sound pretty good and again these
are 100 bucks which is I think a pretty
good price considering you get the
charging case and the water resistance
so obviously you're not gonna be getting
high-end audio quality out of these
things but for what they are I mean I
like them I just have a hard time with
these types of headphones to fit in my
ear like even ear pods so these are a
little bit bigger than the air pods it
might be something that you do want to
try to test out so if the air pods do
work for you these also might work but
again I
like weirdly shaped ears and very small
so even the air pods still kind of fall
out so these are much smaller and right
now Siri is listening to everything
oopsie so now I have the air pods in I
do think of the air pods these are the
original version just feel like there's
a little more bass like things back in
oh yeah there's definitely more bass in
the air pause guess as far as size goes
it's almost the same size it's the new
air pod pros but these are like $300
this is a completely unfair comparison I
mean obviously the air pods Pro are
gonna have a much higher sound quality
[Music]
everything
so this was the Razer hammerhead
wireless earbuds Fraser has had earbuds
like this in the past but they weren't
wireless so this is exciting that
they're also getting into the game but
honestly it is so overwhelming like like
I said earlier I can't believe how many
companies are coming out with something
very similar to this so I think all
things considered when you're looking at
what headphones to get if you're looking
for an ear pods for placement or a
substitution because you don't want the
air pods for whatever reason that is I
actually think these are really great
but I will warn you if you do have
trouble with those types of in-ear
headphones these ones much like any
other headphones of the similar nature
they might give you trouble anything if
you are again looking for something
different than the air pods and
something that is only a hundred dollars
with a charging case I also love that it
has super low latency so again Razer is
mostly known for gaming so if you do
have a Razer phone this would perfectly
complement your Razer phone I'd love to
hear from you guys what headphones are
you guys currently using and if you have
any type of earbuds which ones do you
have and which ones do you really want
I'll put a link in the description if
you guys want to get more information
about this this is not a sponsored video
but Razer did send me these to check out
and as you guys know I'm a huge Razer
fan so I love checking out some of the
new stuff that they're coming out with
they have so much new stuff that they
just announced and it's coming in the
future I'm overwhelmed I will see you
guys in my next video and I look forward
to chatting with you guys in the
comments and if you haven't subscribed
already be sure to do so and I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
you